[Music]
stefano is here to remind you that a
body that looks like this
also looks like this
[Music]
she's a fitness content creator on a
mission to show her followers that not
everything you see on social media is
real
[Music]
today we're going to be looking at
influencers who photoshopped their getty
images from mega popular events
if you don't know what getty images are
basically it's like stock photos and the
photographers that you see at events
like the mac gala and other big events
like that are probably shooting for
getty images up first we have kylie
jenner you can see the getty logo
compared to the one that she actually
posted and the waist is completely
different
next up we have gigi hadid who is
arguably one of the world's top models
getty image versus the one she posted on
instagram see the difference in the
waist and the shoulder
finally we have dove cameron i mean this
change here is drastic but if you hadn't
seen the getty image you wouldn't expect
it at all it looks so natural these
women are literally on the front of the
top magazines in the world for their
beauty and even they are facetuning
their instagram content
lots of people turn to social media for
fitness inspiration but what they're
seeing is often photoshopped airbrushed
filtered or at the very least extremely
posed
and it can be really damaging for the
mental health and self-esteem of people
of all ages but especially for young
people
cellulite acne stretch marks and tummy
rolls are all completely normal and
she's not afraid to show people her
authentic self
[Music]
just want to remind you don't believe
everything you see on instagram
[Music]
[Music]
you